Recommended adaptogen that is great for reducing cortisol and inflammation, but also one that does not increase estrogen.
I have a history of estrogen dominance, uterine cancer, and cannot risk increasing estrogen, but also need to support my cortisol levels.
So, I think this question stems off of some information about some adaptogens that can be estrogenic.
So, I'm trying to think of which ones were more estrogenic than other ones on maybe it will come to me, but that can be an issue.
But with anything like this, I would suggest you measure your hormones.
So, this is something that's missed almost across the board with oncology. I just don't get it.
They'll tell women that they're ERPR positive or HER2 positive, but then they'll never measure their estrogens.
I just don't understand it. I mean, it's just here you're going to have to take this, this aromatase inhibitor for the next 10 years, because why? Because that's what we do.
When, why do we do it? Unfortunately, the truth behind that is because that's what the pharmaceutical company told us to do.
So, in order, if I don't do this and I don't recommend this, I can get in trouble, and now I can even be sued because I'm not doing what's called standards of care.
Well, who wrote standards of care? Well, the pharmaceutical company.
Well, aren't the other ones who sell the product that you're trying to push on me? Oh, well, just ignore that fact.
So, the truth is that, yeah, you should be conscious of your estrogens, but shouldn't you measure them?
And you should, doing a Dutch test can be a great test to measure your hormones.
So, you don't just have estrogen and progesterone or testosterone, you have all these intermediate metabolites.
So, you want to look at the two hydroxy, the four hydroxy, and the 16 hydroxy esteroids, that's the E1.
And these are the ones that can be issues, the four and the 16 can be issues.
So, you want to look at those and measure those.
Some people can be exposed to not just different adaptogens, but other things in their environment that can stimulate estrogen production,
or that can act like Xedoestrogens in their body and not somebody else's.
So, measuring that can be very beneficial.
So, there are different adaptogens that can help reduce cortisol, but I also would recommend that you measure your cortisol.
So, you know, we always think that everything in the body is, you know, either all good, or all bad,
because we read some article about it, or because that's the kind of the current hype in the natural seed.
And cortisol always gets the bad rap, right?
Access cortisol to stress hormone, and we don't want cortisol.
And cortisol is my problem, and cortisol is why I can't go to sleep at night.
And cortisol is this, well, you can't blame something that you don't measure.
So, that might not be true.
There's lots of reasons why a person can't fall asleep.
And lots of people, reasons why a person, you know, can't lose weight.
There's lots of reasons why that we're giving a bad rap to something.
We need to measure it.
So, measuring cortisol levels can be very beneficial.
I can't tell you how many people that you do a Dutch test and you do a Dutch complete,
which does have a cortisol measurement in it too.
And their cortisol levels are down in the dump.
So, they have a adrenal fatigue is what they have, or a adrenal burnout.
So, their adrenals are burned out, they're not getting enough cortisol.
If you don't have enough cortisol, remember, everything's not bad, or everything's not good.
It's about balance.
If you don't have a balance of cortisol in your body, you won't break down glucose.
You won't break down glycogen stores.
You will have tons of brain fog and issues because your brain needs glucose in order to feed off.
And if you don't have enough glucose for your brain, especially at night,
you're going to have all sorts of issues waking up at night and such.
And it's a decrease amount of cortisol.
So, we need to build up the adrenal glands.
Maybe it's adrenal tissue that that person needs, not so much an adaptogen.
Maybe it needs they need pituitary tissue to help stimulate adrenal flow.
Maybe they, so there's lots of different things that we want to look at.
So, we certainly don't want to, if you have a history of uterine cancer or history of breast cancer,
that was a horrible driven.
You want to look at zero estrogens.
You want to look at estrogen levels and those bad estrogen levels.
So, running a Dutch test would be the best thing to do.
You really want to measure it.